foreign
MacBook Air review this laptop
thankfully is exactly what you think it
is it's a MacBook Air
but bigger this is the Tesla Model y of
laptops you see the Tesla Model 3 was
the most important model for Tesla they
had other more expensive flagships but
this was the entry level attainable
version for the masses and it quickly
became their most recommended and
best-selling car and it's the way that
most people got into Tesla and formed
their first Tesla experience but
sneakily bigger cars are actually more
popular and in America especially people
can't help but want a version that's a
little bigger a little higher off the
ground so they did the obvious thing and
made Tesla Model y it's built on the
same platform as a model 3 but a little
bigger and a little higher off the
ground and pretty much instantly has
rocketed up to the top of the lineup to
the point where it's now the most
popular new car on planet Earth
see the MacBook Air was the most
important Mac for Apple I mean they had
other expensive flagships but this was
the most entry-level attainable model
for the masses and it quickly became
their most recommended and best-selling
Mac as the first first way most people
got into the mac and formed their first
Mac OS experiences but sneakily bigger
screens are actually the most popular
and in America especially people can't
help but want a version with a little
bit of a bigger screen so they did the
obvious thing and made the 15-inch
MacBook Air it's built on the same
platform as the 14-inch MacBook Air but
a little bit bigger screen and I predict
it'll pretty much instantly rock it to
the top of the lineup to the point where
it is the most popular 50-inch laptop
and the most popular Mac on planet Earth
we kind of already know what the M2
MacBook Air is if you haven't already
seen it I'll link the review right with
the like button that covers it my only
real question is going into the review
of the bigger one were one is there any
real benefit to the bigger screen how
much better is it really and two are
there any other benefits to getting a
bigger laptop so I think the whole
bigger screen thing is pretty clear
there are literally millions of people
who today go into stores and ask for a
15-inch laptop and when they did Apple
would have to bring people over to the
16-inch MacBook Pro as their cheapest
option which starts at twenty five
hundred dollars so now they have this
now is there a dramatically more
information that can fit on the screen
not really is it a dramatically better
quality display than the smaller one nah
it mostly just feels bigger uh bigger
videos bigger movies bigger texts bigger
Windows just just a little more room for
everything to be a little bit bigger and
you only pay for that really with a
little bit of extra size as far as the
laptop goes this thing is still 11 and a
half millimeters thin and weighs 3.3
pounds it's super slim it's a quarter of
a millimeter thicker and half a pound
heavier than the smaller MacBook Air
which I kind of mentioned this earlier
but I forgot that basically already has
14 inch diagonal screens with its
thinner bezels so you can really just
measure out 1.3 extra inches diagonally
to get to the proper 15.3 inch laptop
size still it has decently thin bezels
not the thinnest in the world still has
the notch cut out for face ID I mean
sorry no face ID it has just a webcam
and a microphone it still just as Touch
ID on the keyboard and nothing else
about the display itself really has
changed it's the same Tech the same
pixel density the same brightness 500
nits 60 hertz it's fine the screen is
fine it's just bigger so all right now
that the whole footprint of the laptop
is also bigger what more can you get out
of that uh first of all sneaky slightly
bigger track pad so the keyboard is the
same size but actually the trackpad does
get a little bit bigger which is nice
kind of matches the larger display and
also there is more room inside for
speakers so Apple's added not bigger
speakers but just actually a second set
of force canceling woofers which would
theoretically make the sound a little
punchier maybe add some bass and I I can
say it is louder it does get louder
overall and have a bit more bass than
the smaller MacBook Air but it's not
like game changing I'm impressed that
they can get loud without distorting but
they are not close to the maybe unfair
16 inch MacBook Pro speakers but just to
give you an idea of the context also
some people have noted it looks kind of
weird to have like no speaker grilles
the left and right of the keyboard but
the speakers are still in the same place
as they were in the smaller one up in
the hinge of the MacBook Air and then
there's also more room inside for bigger
battery and my experience actually lines
up pretty well with what Apple said
which is look it's the same chipset very
similar laptop bigger screen and bigger
battery sort of cancel each other out
and you end up with roughly the same
battery life as a smaller machine it has
to say it's quite good full workday of
battery life pretty much guaranteed
multiple light days in a row no problem
so then the last thing I wanted to test
is actually is there a difference in
performance between the small M2 MacBook
Air and the big one since theoretically
there is just a little more room inside
for a little extra thermal Headroom like
there's no way it's significant but
these are very different size laptops
and the old one when it was torn apart
didn't have a heat sink so maybe there's
room for a little passive heatsink in
this one they're both fanless but I had
to check it so in single core bursty
performance I never expect to see any
difference and I really didn't I ran off
back-to-back geekbench 6 benchmarks
small drop off after the first one for
each but no noticeable difference but
then I ran back to back 10 minute
cinebench multi-core benchmarks which
kind of just run continuously to test
some more reliable sustained workloads
and there was a slightly bigger dip on
the smaller M2 air and so potentially
yes over time this may add up to a bit
more thermal throttling but my
conclusion is you can see the numbers on
paper but this difference is unlikely to
be noticeable like I said they're both
running the M2 Chip and most behavior on
laptops like this is so bursty and short
that they perform basically identically
but if you do happen to get into those
long multi-minit sustained workloads in
a row like we're exporting a video
editing a video gaming even then maybe
you'd notice a little bit more out of
this bigger one over time but you'll
notice the bigger difference on the
14-inch MacBook Pro which is just a
little bit above this one in price so if
you know you're going to be doing
workloads like that then you probably
are looking at a Pro laptop but matter
of fact let's just talk about what I
think is the biggest X Factor with this
laptop the biggest hurdle between this
and being the Tesla Model y of laptops
is the price so this Baseline version
this little Starlight one which kind of
almost matches this a little bit a
little sand color starts at 12.99 and
that is the base version which you you
can't upgrade these laptops over time so
you tend to want to get as much as you
can out of the initial purchase this
base version only has eight gigs of
shared memory and 256 gigs of storage
that can actually pretty quickly become
a 1700 laptop with just a few clicks to
upgrade those things and that's a that's
pricey so there's a lot of Windows
laptops that you can get at that price
that will probably do one specific thing
better than this one whether it's the
XPS 15 with a nicer display or the Rog
zephyrus which is going to be better for
gaming and has more ports you can get
flipping and folding laptops that spin
over backwards and gaming laptops even
but none of them will be quite the
package that this this is which is a
really thin and light daily 15 inch
screen laptop like this is kind of just
the ultimate Baseline for most people's
activities so to have all those things
sort of well-rounded into one the
thinness and lightness the nice display
the great battery life the impressive
performance from the M2 that's what
makes this the MacBook Air it's got the
A1 build quality it's got the color
matching braided magsafe cable which
also connects to the 35 watt charging
brick with dual USBC ports which you
could actually swap out for a slightly
larger 70 watt brick with a single port
for faster charging that's a free swap
on Apple site and of course you can't
forget the ecosystem stuff the messages
the FaceTime Etc all the stuff that
plugs into Apple's World despite its
potentially premium price
people will pounce on this popular pick
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one peace
[Music]